all right
settle down fellas
i'm here all night um
i make i drive the guys wild i'm so you
know what's so crazy because my brother
like loves your show that's not crazy no
i know it's that's good wait i'm get i'm
getting somewhere and he's he's you know
he now i feel like i've made it to him
because like he watches
your monologue and like all the crazy
faces and up in the camera like he gets
really excited about it yeah and um and
then he's probably gonna turn it off now
that i'm on because all he cares about
is you
and uh but he's 12.
wow
yeah that's what happens to me i can't
tell you how often i have uh people come
up to me in the street and be like oh
you know older one will come my son
loves you he thinks you're the best and
be like well thank you very much how old
is he he's seven
he loves when you dance around like a
chimpanzee he does he thinks it's the
best yeah well
he's like oh my god he's cracked up well
i'm putting my college education to work
by hopping around like a maniac well
thank you for being here i'm glad you're
here you flew out here which is a big
deal for you because you're i hate
flying you hate to fly yeah it's like
the worst but i'm getting better because
you know i gotta i have to i mean you
know we gotta fly but i you know try and
talk to the pilots about like
what they did the night before and like
are you guys drunk can you handle a
plane today i bet they love that when
you come barging into the cockpit you've
probably been drinking
first of all when are you talking to the
pilots because the thing is you know
when like a star requests like first
class because she wants like big seats
and all this i just want to be as close
as i can to the pilot you know so i can
monitor what's going on but now you know
it's a little bit more secretive but
whatever it's like you like to monitor
what's going on
i like to feel like i have like some
sort of like control i don't know right
right but you ever think you're making
the situation worse that you're
distracting the pilots they're trying to
bring the plane down you're like look
it's alicia cuthbert you know no no no
not at all it makes me feel more
confident like if they if they look like
they know what they're doing and
everything's cool i'm like oh i have
nothing to worry about but if like
they're like oh what was that i'm like
oh like i freak out yeah i don't like it
when the pilot says ooh what was that
either
no exactly so i my wife got really mad
at me because we flew like a week ago
and just before the plane took off the
pilot just walked down the aisle and
said hello everybody i'm the pilot joe
he was like this good looking guy in his
50s and he came up and was like you know
take care everybody my 11 year old loves
you and then uh he went back we went
back into the uh cockpit and i just
turned to my wife and i went that man
was clearly drunk and uh
interesting do you really think so
that's what i don't know i said no i
don't think so she's like don't talk
about
holding on that everything for dear life
going tell me he's not do you do
anything so some people that are afraid
to fly have little
rituals yeah i have all kinds of things
i don't want to give them all away
because if i do then maybe they won't
work anymore but like i'll give you like
a couple because i have like 100 but
like i have to walk on the plane with my
right foot first
and like
all through the plane you have to walk
one foot at a time
i'm going to the bathroom
i hop there
no no just you get on the front okay you
get on no i just i just
as soon as i walk down i have to walk on
with the right foot first and then i'm
like okay it's going to be good and then
like
i don't know there's weird stuff but i
can't you know it's all ways to just try
and get control you know that just to
feel like you're in control of a
situation yeah it's sick isn't it that's
not sick i think it's very human
i love you now uh
let's talk about this uh this movie this
in this
in this movie you're you're playing a
former porn star
so to prepare for this you actually
studied
magazines like hustler playboy things
like i went no i didn't really i didn't
study them i was kind of oh i thought we
had something in common
no i was going i've studied them
i was you know who's like miss april oh
yeah
um no you know we
wanna
i think she actually is because
i was you know to set a look for you
know the former porn star because she
kind of comes in and out of the film but
um you kind of get numb to it though
don't you no
really
not yet
i'm getting up there there's no numbness
see that's the thing is
this is the sad thing about men and i'm
going to be honest here is that i think
women can get numb to these things but
men i'll be 90. and if the nurse like
shows me i'll be like
that's sad i guess because i see my own
every morning i don't really you know
whatever it's different i don't look at
my body and go hey
yeah well no one does but anyway
the point is
the point is that yeah i know you don't
get it guys no
to get this part you kind of had to
convince the director that you'd be able
to do it that you
well because first of all i
anyone who's close to me knows that like
on my everyday life i'm not i don't wear
makeup i don't dress up you know high
heels or whatever you know and so i
walked into the meeting and obviously
had to kind of convince the director
that i could be like this hot you know
girl next door slash former porn star
and here i am like looking like a bum
off the street but um but i had like
polaroids of like fhm in my pocket and i
was like look i i can actually look good
i probably have a shoot that you had
done were you yeah i was like all like i
had fake like hair extensions and like
some little bikini thing and i was like
look it's possible did he take those
photos
did you get them back i'll peruse these
i'll see you later no i did i did get
them back but it helped because then he
you know he was like wow that's great
you can see what you can we have a clip
here from the movie what do we need to
know to appreciate what's happening here
well you just have to watch to
appreciate i think
wow
that is a great no i'm gonna say i hear
a lot of setups and i love that because
a lot of people go like well okay here's
what you have to know there's a
scientist in medieval france and then he
gets on the time machine and he goes to
the future and he makes a giant eclair
and then you know murray this is very
straightforward this is what people want
people everyone's gonna enjoy it learn
celebrities just say take a look at the
clip right that's all people want to see
yeah roll it
i'm all wet can i come in
hey guys uh this is danielle
you must be eli
and clix right hey come on we're all
going out
today is your bathroom first
oh uh it's it's over here to the left
dude
i know
dude
i know
you don't need to set it up you're right
yeah
that's the way yeah the nerdy kid on the
left with the bowl haircut that could
have been me and hi it looks like me
right now you know i guess like you know
no it doesn't
uh the girl next door opens on friday 24
which everyone always on people's list
of like best show 24 airs tuesdays at
9pm on fox it was your first it was
great having you here alicia cuthbert
everybody